looking back on your guys wild boy
career what what
what stands out what country stands out
to you guys
i mean the the burning down of the three
cabins is always gonna be
like uh was africa kicking off kicking
off the show yeah that was the start
right
yeah yeah yeah to me i don't know
everywhere was rad
like it was everyone's an intense era
man like the wild boys
era was just like wow man so much life
experience packed into like
whatever it was three years and uh it
was a lot of work
how many countries in three years i
don't know
um i mean we had double passports though
like like
our passports like were filled up so
then you can
get extra pages yeah we had to have
double pages and those got filled up
like and then i got the third set of
pages
yeah oh my god one time during wild
voice stevo was
was showing off his passport to me how
many um
like this was in the middle of wow boys
like see i've got double pages and like
he's showing me how full it is i'm like
i know dude i'm i was with you
yeah that's so funny
was the poo condom only on wild boys or
was that other was that jackass too
ah it was wild boys yeah
we didn't go like did we weren't doing
that on your
on your own tour steve where you'd
swallowed dress i didn't go anywhere i
wouldn't be able to get drugs like
swallowing condoms full of
weed was only only for going anywhere in
the west or the eastern hemisphere
and so everybody had to do it right he
no
no not everyone's home but but steve
would get really grumpy if you didn't
have it
yeah like in indonesia i remember you
were really grumpy really grumpy we were
there for
three [ __ ] weeks dude couldn't smoke
pot for three weeks i was
not happy yeah dude